an important application of the central
limit theorem is in the approximate
calculation of the binomial
probabilities here is what is involved
we start with random variables X I that
are independent and they have the same
distribution they're all Bernoulli with
parameter P we add n of those random
variables and the resulting random
variable s n we know that it has a
binomial PMF with parameters N and P we
also know it's mean and we do know it's
variance what the central limit theorem
tells us in this case since we're
dealing with the sum of independent
identically distributed random variables
is the following if we take this random
variable here that we have been denoting
by Zn which is a standardized version of
s and we subtract the mean of SN and
divide by the standard deviation this
random variable has a CDF that
approaches as n goes to infinity the CDF
of a standard normal so let us use what
we now know to calculate some
probabilities let us fix some parameters
and is 36 P is 0.5 and we wish to
calculate the probability that SN is
less than or equal to 21 now in this
case we can calculate it exactly using
the binomial formula the probability of
being less than or equal to 21 is the
sum of the probabilities of all the
numbers from 0 to 21 and this is the
probability of obtaining a number K and
by calculating this expression we obtain
this number which is the exact answer
now let us proceed using the central
limit theorem we are interested in this
probability but we will use the fact
about the CDF of this related random
variable so the first step is to
calculate n times P which is 18 the
second step is to calculate this
denominator here which in our case
evaluates to 3 now since we know
something about the CDF of this random
variable what we need to do is to take
this event and rewrite it in terms of
this random variable so we have the
event of interest which is that SN is
less than or equal to 21 this is the
same as the event that SN minus 18 is
less than or equal to 21 minus 18 and
it's the same as this event here where
we divide both sides by 3 now what we
have here is the probability that this
random variable Z n is less than or
equal to 1
but now Zn is approximately a standard
normal so we can use here the CDF of the
standard normal distribution which is
Phi of 1 and at this point we look at
the tables for the normal distribution
we find this entry here and this gives
us an answer of 0.8 for 1/3 this is a
pretty good approximation of the exact
answer which is 0.8 7 8 5 but it is not
a great approximation it is off by about
4 percentage points can we do better
than that it turns out that we can get a
better approximation and let us see how
this can be done recall that we
approximated this probability using the
central limit theorem and found this
numerical value but we make an
observation that this probability is
equal to this probability here why is
that SN is an integer random variable
therefore if I tell you that it is
strictly less than 22 I'm also telling
you that it is 21 or less therefore this
event here is the same as that event
here and therefore their probabilities
are the same so instead of using the
central limit approximation to calculate
this probability let us follow the same
procedure but trying to calculate this
probability here and this probability
here is equal to the probability that SN
minus we subtract the mean divided by
the standard deviation of SN is strictly
less than 22 minus 18 divided by 3 which
is the probability that the random
variable that we denote by Zn which is
this expression here is strictly less
than 22 minus 18 over 3 this is 1.33
now at this point we pretend that Zn is
a standard normal random variable the
probability that the standard normal is
less than a certain number this is the
standard normal CDF evaluated at that
number and then we look up at the normal
tables at 1.33 and we find this value of
0.9 o8 2 now we compare this value with
the exact answer for this problem and we
see that we again missed it using this
approximation to this quantity gave us
an underestimate of this number now we
obtained an over estimate the true value
is somewhere in the middle so this
suggests that we may want to do
something that combines these two
alternative choices here but before
doing that it's good to understand what
exactly have we been doing all along
what we're doing is the following we
have the PMF of the binomial centered at
18 which is the mean it's a discrete
random variable but when we use the
central limit theorem we pretend that
the binomial is normal but while we keep
the same mean and variance now when we
calculate probabilities if we want to
find the discrete probability that SN is
less than or equal to 21 which is the
sum of these probabilities what we do is
we look at the area under the normal PDF
from 21 and below in the alternative
approach when we use the central limit
theorem to approximate the probability
of this event we go to 22 and we look
the at the event of falling below 22
this means that we're looking at the
area from 22 and lower so in one
approach this particular region is not
used in the
halation that's what we did here but in
the second approach it was used in the
calculation should it be used or not it
makes more sense to use only part of
this solid region and assign it to the
calculation of the probability of being
a twenty-one or less namely we can take
the midpoint here where the midpoint is
at 21 and a half and calculate the area
under the normal PDF only going up to 21
and a half what this amounts to is
looking at this particular event here
now this event is of course identical to
these events that we have been
considering because again SN is a
discrete random variable that takes
integer values but when we approximated
by a normal it does make a difference
whether we write the event this way or
that way so here we're going to obtain
the probability that the standardized
version of Zn is less than we follow the
same calculation but now we have 21 and
a half minus 18 divided by 3 and this
number here is 1 point 17 and using the
central limit theorem calculation this
is the CDF of the standard normal
evaluated at one point 17 which we can
go and look up in the normal table to
find the value of 0.879 0 and now we
notice that this value is remarkably
close to the true value it is much
better as an approximation that what we
obtained using either this choice or
that choice and since this approximation
is so good
we may consider even using it to
approximate individual probabilities of
the binomial PMF let's see what that
takes let us try to approximate as an
example the probability that SN
the value of exactly 19 so what we will
do will be to write the event that SN is
equal to 19 as the event that SN lies
between 18 and 1/2 and 19 and 1/2 in
terms of the picture that we were
discussing before what we are doing
essentially is to take the area under
the normal PDF that extends from 18 and
1/2 to 19 and 1/2 and declare that this
area corresponds to the discrete event
that our binomial random variable takes
a value of 19 similarly if we wanted to
calculate approximately the value of the
probability that SN takes a value of 21
we would consider the area under the
normal PDF from 20 and 1/2 to 21 and 1/2
so let us now continue with this
approach we do the usual calculations
which is to express this event in terms
of standardized values that is we
subtract throughout the mean of SN and
divide by its standard deviation so what
we obtain here is the standardized
version of SN and that has to be now
less than or equal to 19 and 1/2 minus
18 divided by 3 which is the probability
that our standardized random variable
lies between point 17 and point 5 and
now if we pretend that Zn is a standard
normal random variable which is what the
central limit theorem suggests this is
going to be equal to the probability
that the standard normal is less than or
equal to 0.5 minus the probability that
it is less than point 17 and if we look
up those entries in the normal tables
what we find is an answer of 6.15
I knows this number which evaluates to
zero point one to four and what is the
exact answer if we were to use the
binomial probability formulas the exact
answer is remarkably close to what we
obtained in our approximation this
example illustrates a more general fact
that this approach of calculating
individual entries of the binomial PMF
gives very accurate answers and in fact
there are theorems there are theoretical
results to this effect that tell us that
this way of approximating asymptotically
as n goes to infinity and in a certain
regime does give us very accurate
approximations